[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend alle gatto hieß es heute in
tokio dank an die japanischen gastgeber
die spiele sind beendet die schlussfeier
beeindruckte mit einer ausgeklügelten
lichtshow perfekt in szene gesetzt im
stadion von tokio
die olympischen ringe leuchteten über
den athleten die sich verabschiedeten
allerdings vor leeren zuschauerrängen
auch dass ein symbolbild dieser
umstrittenen spielen das ioc feiert sie
als erfolg und spricht von der
olympischen seele die trotz pandemie
beschränkungen allenthalben zu spüren
gewesen sei und die japanischen
gastgeber wirkten vor allem erleichtert
dass sie die ganze sache gut über die
bühne gebracht haben
in japan selbst hatte es ja erhebliche
bedenken gegeben angesichts dieses
internationalen großereignisses inmitten
der pandemie welche bilanz können die
gastgeber für sich ziehen der frage ist
martin niesen nachgegangen japan feiert
abschied und präsentiert sich der welt
noch einmal als das was es die
vergangenen zweieinhalb wochen war ein
bestmöglicher gastgeber
[Musik]
tokio 2020 erst als wiederaufbau spiele
nach der tsunami- und atomkatastrophe
von 2011 deklariert dann zum symbol des
sieges über das corona virus
umetikettiert aus beidem wurde nichts
lob gibt es dennoch
[Musik]
die japanische bevölkerung kann sehr
stolz auf das erreichte sein und
deswegen sagen wir im namen aller
athleten danke tokio danke japan die
spiele im ausnahmezustand spalteten das
land da waren sportbegeisterte
japanerinnen und japaner die mit stolz
sich und ihre gastgeberrolle
zelebrierten aber auch jene die das
großereignis ablehnten oder zumindest
hoffen dass es schnell und geräuschlos
vorbeigehe
dann aber stiegen die infektionszahlen
auf immer neue rekordhöhen die regierung
versagte bei der impfstoff beschaffung
der mangel paarte sich mit skepsis der
bevölkerung nach impfschäden in der
vergangenheit und olympia verschärfte
die situation zumindest indirekt die
spieler haben das verhalten der menschen
negativ beeinflusst die leute denken
athleten und politiker feiern dieses
großereignis und wir sollen zu hause
bleiben wir wollen rausgehen wie die die
spiele von tokio ohne zuschauer ein
reines tv-event wären mit kosten von
vermutlich mindestens 25 milliarden euro
die teuersten der geschichte die
pandemie ließ einnahmen implodieren und
kosten explodieren die austragung der
spiele hat dem bruttosozialprodukt zwar
ein plus von rund 2,3 milliarden euro
beschert das ist allerdings nur etwa ein
sechstel des erwarteten die zeitgleiche
verhängung des ausnahmezustands hat die
wirtschaft rund 5,8 milliarden gekostet
so dass am ende ein dickes minus steht
am tag der abschlussfeier stürmten viele
menschen die lange verwaisten
souvenirläden als hätten sie am ende
doch ihren frieden mit diesen spielen
gemacht
der sport und die erfolge der athleten
haben uns in dieser schwierigen zeit
glückliche momente beschert dann wird
noch die olympische flagge an paris
weitergereicht austragungsort 20 24 und
in tokio erlischt die flamme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
welche letzten wettkämpfe ist heute noch
gab und wie die sportliche bilanz dieser
spiele für das deutsche olympiateam
aussieht dazu kommen wir dann noch
ausführlich am ende der sendung rekord
regen und hochwasser in deutschland
rekordhitze in kanada mit fast 50 grad
verheerende brände in griechenland und
der türkei von denen man in beiden
ländern sagt dass das historische
ausmaße haben
das ist ein dramatischer hintergrund vor
dem morgen der weltklimarat seinen
bericht vorlegen wird den letzten
umfänglichen sachstandsbericht zum
klimawandel gab es vor rund sieben
jahren
seitdem konnten forscher weltweit neue
daten sammeln und mit ihren prognosen
abgleichen detail bericht der morgen
erscheint wird den neuesten stand der
wissenschaft abbilden und nach dem was
bereits öffentlich geworden ist sind die
schlussfolgerungen für die knapp 200
mitgliedstaaten des klimarats
alarmierend gerade auch für den
mittelmeerraum
dazu gleich noch ein gespräch doch
zunächst erläutert dalian tavi die
wissenschaft die zusammenhänge zwischen
klima und wetter erklärt im süden
europas wie hier in griechenland toben
beispiellose waldbrände nach einer
langen phase der dürre
der kampf gegen die flammen oft
aussichtslos vielen bleibt nur die
flucht raus aus dem inferno dazu
temperaturen zwischen 40 und 50 grad
celsius im norden ein anderes bild
dauerregen der sich tage bis wochen hält
wassermassen die sich bahn brechen ganze
orte verwüsten existenzen zerstören
wir sehen hier diese unsichtbare hand
und diese unsichtbare hand ist die
globale erwärmung die führt eben in
unterschiedlichen regionen zu ganz
unterschiedlichen auswirkungen aber
insgesamt wird es überall extremer und
die extreme halten häufig an
grund dafür ist der höhenwind der
jetstream sagen forschende so strömt
warme luft vom süden richtung nordpol
und wird abgelenkt der motor für den
jetstream der hohe temperatur und damit
druckunterschied zwischen den tropen und
den polarregionen
doch dieser unterschied wird immer
kleiner es wird wärmer in der atmosphäre
der jetstream verliert an kraft und
schlingert
sahara luft dringt so zb aus dem süden
vor und kann über einer region über tage
und wochen verharren
ob die erderwärmung der auslöser für den
erschlafften jetstream ist darüber ist
sich die wissenschaft nicht einig für
diese erwärmung sind klimaschädliche
treibhausgase verantwortlich und die
sind menschengemacht daran lässt der
weltklimarat in seinem letzten bericht
kaum zweifel
es ist äußerst wahrscheinlich dass der
einfluss des menschen die hauptursache
der beobachteten erwärmung seit mitte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war es ist
seit weit über 100 jahren bekannt dass
treibhausgase wie co2 beispielsweise die
erde erwärmen und wir haben in den
letzten jahrzehnten einen massiven
anstieg der toskana luft gehabt und
deswegen so zwangsläufig dass sich die
erde auch massiv verändert ziel des
klimaabkommens von paris war den anstieg
der temperatur auf 1,5 grad im vergleich
zum vorindustriellen zeitalter zu
begrenzen
doch wenn der ausstoß klimaschädlicher
treibhausgase weitergeht könnte die
temperatur auf der erde bis zum ende des
jahrhunderts um 4 grad steigen sagen
forschende einer wärmeren welt ist mehr
wasserdampf in der luft bugrad 7 prozent
mehr wasser drang von bei entsprechender
wetterlage kann das dann auch als regen
rinnt runterkommen und deswegen ist es
zwangsläufig dass wenn sich die erde
erwärmt wir auch häufiger starkregen
haben
damit werden so forschende wetter
extreme dann nicht nur häufiger sondern
auch heftiger und das ist uns der klima-
forscher anders levermann vom potsdam
institut für klimafolgenforschung
zugeschaltet so nahm professor lieberman
und wie sehr sich die erde erwärmt das
wird auch morgen in dem bericht des
weltklimarats ein großes thema seien sie
kennen natürlich diese ganzen daten was
ist er als zentrale aussage zu erwarten
der bericht der ja noch nicht öffentlich
ist sehr wird das sagen was wir seit 20
jahren sagen nur mit noch mehr
sicherheit mit noch mehr mit noch mehr
stärke tatsächlich denn es ist
physikalisch einfach ganz eindeutig das
co2 die temperatur des planeten erhöht
und dass wir tatsächlich auch eine ganze
reihe von nebeneffekten haben die meeres
steigen an
weil sich das wasser erwärmt und damit
aus denen das eis an den polen schmilzt
die klimaregionen verschieben sich aber
das was tatsächlich im bericht ja
anklang und was das entscheidende ist
die wetter- extreme nehmen zu und das
ist das was uns tatsächlich weiter in
atem halten wird und auch immer stärker
wird also einerseits extreme dürren mit
dann auch mit waldbrandgefahr ist er
jetzt gerade mittelmeerraum sehen
andererseits mehr regen gibt es
natürlich immer auch noch stimmen die
sagen ja also einzelne wetterphänomene
kann man nicht immer so mit dem
klimawandel rückkoppeln wie erklären sie
das es müssen ja auch gar nicht wir
müssen es geht ja nicht darum ob das
letzte starke niederschlag zeigen dass
vom klimawandel beurteilt wurde sondern
was der zukunft passiert und was wir
gerade schon gehört haben und was seit
1843 in der physik bekannt ist dass
klaus klavon gesetzt das heißt wärmere
atmosphäre hält mehr wasserdampf und
dieser dieses zusätzliche hat dieser
zusätzliche wasserdampf der entlädt sich
in starken niederschlags ereignissen und
deswegen müssen wir davon ausgehen dass
stark nieder startseite und
überschwemmung immer häufiger immer
häufiger in der zukunft passieren wenn
wir nicht auf den planeten zu erwerben
in dem bericht vom weltklimarat soll es
auch ein kapitel geben dass ich fang auf
den mittelmeerraum bezieht und von einem
hotspot spricht der erderwärmung was ist
dort zu erwarten
wir haben die ganze reihe von hotspots
auf der erde wir merken das ja auch
gerade wie ein feuerwerk von
wetterextremen dass wir da beobachten
damit die mittelmeerregion ist
tatsächlich sehr sehr trocken das
beobachten wir auch schon seit 50 jahren
immer immer stärker und das wird sich
auch in zukunft weiter weiter vollziehen
das problem ist dass damit natürlich
waldbrände häufiger werden die
wasserknappheit zunimmt usw und hitze
also man fragt sich ja ob man überhaupt
noch ohne klimaanlagen auf dauer wird
auskommen kann das dann ja auch wieder
nicht wirklich ökologisch
na ja darum geht es tatsächlich in
diesem fall nicht wir müssen uns
natürlich an den klimawandel den wir
schon verursacht haben anpassen
deswegen werden wir auch aircondition
bekommen wir erst werden wir bekommen in
den krankenhäusern und in den da wo die
wo die schwachen und die die kranken
sind aber dann müssen wir uns
gleichzeitig natürlich müssen wir den
klimawandel vermeiden
an den wir uns nicht anpassen können und
das ist das was wir beobachten überall
auf der welt fangen die wetter- extreme
werden immer intensiver und wir müssen
uns vor diesen vor diesem
unkontrollierbaren klimawandel schützen
und das geht nur dadurch dass sie die
co2 emission runterfahren
das ist er optimistisch dass das noch
gelingt oder blicken sie da doch eher
mit der sorge oder auch furcht in die
zukunft wir haben tatsächlich die
richtigen fade gesetzt wir haben in
nordamerika von kanada bis die usa wir
haben wir vertreter die jetzt
tatsächlich den klimaschutz ernst nehmen
europa hat gesagt keine
verbrennungsmotoren
ab 2035 und wir haben auch tatsächlich
in china an den partner der zwar
heimlich und still und leise aber doch
in die richtige richtung zieht aber wir
müssen das jetzt weiter fahren das ist
keine radikale politische aussage wir
müssen auf null emissionen in 20 jahren
sagt der klimaforscher an dass lieberman
ich danke für das gespräch sehr gerne zu
den politischen nebenwirkungen der
hochwasserkatastrophe in rheinland-pfalz
und nordrhein-westfalen gehört dass sie
erstaunlicherweise den kandidaten bei
denen man das am ehesten vermuten könnte
keinen auftrieb gibt nicht dem
nrw-ministerpräsidenten armin laschet
dem die rolle des tatkräftigen
landesvaters nicht so gelungen ist wie
man das hätte erwarten können aber auch
nicht annalena baerbock obwohl das thema
klimawandel
doch ein wahrlich uhr grünes ist wo
stehen die grünen im moment in ihrem
wahlkampf und wie wollen sie die fehler
die in den letzten wochen passiert sind
noch ausgleichen
fragen zu denen sich robert habeck heute
im zdf sommerinterview geäußert hat
patrizia wieder mal fast das gespräch
zusammen
flensburg wassers leben hier im hohen
norden ist robert habeck zu hause hier
ist harbeck land jeder kennt ihn
und egal mit wem man spricht sie alle
sind sicher er wäre der bessere kanzler
kandidat jemanden aufzustellen da wenig
politische erfahrung hat er noch kein
ministeramt innehatte oder keinen
überhaupt kein amt in irgendeinem land
war glaube ich hätte gerne dass harbeck
angetreten wäre er ist ein sehr
souveräner aber auch ein authentischer
mensch und das kann man nicht von vielen
politikern behaupten finde ich doch
einen wechsel von annalena baerbock zu
robert habeck was sie hier fordern
schließt er aus nein das ist keine
debatte ist geeignet für das kanzleramt
und unsere aufgabe ist dafür zu sorgen
dass die grünen stark werden und dann
werden wir gucken was dabei rauskommt
wie stark wir werden wie stark sie
werden das werde sich auch hier in
seiner heimat entscheidet hier villa
fehlende stimmen aus dem saarland wieder
gutmachen stimmen die verloren gehen da
wegen formaler fehler die landesliste
nicht für die bundestagswahl zugelassen
wurde eine doofe selbstverschuldete
situation gibt habe ich zu
offensichtlich haben wir es nicht
geschafft und die saarländer auch nicht
wir hätten dann ja vielleicht an alter
stelle unterstützen können das problem
war vorher frühzeitig zu lösen
aber nochmal das ist jetzt alles
vergossene milch jetzt muss man vorne
geschaut werden es ist ärgerlich genug
also müssen wir sehen was wir an anderer
stelle umso besser sind querelen im
saarland fehler der kanzlerkandidatin
wer bock ein holpriger wahlkampfstart es
sei vertrauen verloren gegangen ja aber
vor allem beim thema klimaschutz hätten
nur die grünen die erforderlichen
maßnahmen fahrrad davon handelt der
wahlkampf das hier deutlich machen dass
man uns vertrauen kann dass wir anders
als wettbewerber parteien wissen was die
stunde geschlagen hat wie dringlich die
situation ist und die maßnahmen dafür
auch bereit haben während alle anderen
sich in die büsche schlagen sollten die
grünen künftig mitregieren sollen corona
test nicht kostenpflichtig werden und es
keine allgemeine impfpflicht geben
man hat das recht sich nicht impfen zu
lassen aber man hat nicht das recht dass
alle geimpften und der rest der
gesellschaft und die kinder dann
rücksicht darauf nehmen weil man sich
selbst entschieden hat sein eigenes
leben und
die gesellschaft zu gefährden insgesamt
gibt sich der grüne spitzenkandidat
optimistisch die union habe eigene
probleme noch sei alles möglich spricht
habe sich und seiner partei mut zu
für die kommenden sieben wochen bis zur
bundestagswahl
das vollständige sommerinterview mit
robert habeck können sie auf zdf heute
aufrufen und dort findet sich natürlich
auch jede menge anderes rund um den
bundestagswahlkampf
nach dem abzug der westlichen truppen
aus afghanistan rücken die taliban
weiter vor heute wurde gemeldet dass sie
weite teile von kunduz erobert haben
dort hatte die bundeswehr ein großes
feldlager mit dem thema beginnen jetzt
die nachrichten von heinz wolf ein
großer teil von kundus der hauptstadt
der gleichnamigen provinz soll unter
kontrolle der taliban seien die
afghanischen soldaten halten offenbar
noch den flughafen und ihren eigenen
stützpunkt es gab heftige gefechte und
die afghanischen regierungstruppen
kündigten eine offensive zur
rückeroberung wichtige einrichtungen in
kundus an
neben kundus sollen die taliban noch
weitere provinzhauptstädte eingenommen
haben die verheerenden brände am
mittelmeer wüten weiter in süditalien
bedrohen die feier zunehmend
landwirtschaft und naturschutzgebiete in
regionen griechenlands ist die lage
besonders dramatisch ein großer teil der
insel euböa steht in flammen weitere
einwohner und urlauber wurden mit
schiffen in sicherheit gebracht rund 600
feuerwehrleute kämpfen gegen die brände
unterstützt werden sie aus der luft von
löschflugzeugen aber dichter rauch und
starke hitze erschweren die
löscharbeiten
die eu hat den belarussischen machthaber
lukaschenko zur freilassung politischer
gefangener und zu freien und fairen
wahlen aufgefordert in einer erklärung
des außenbeauftragten borel anlässlich
des jahrestages der präsidentenwahl
heißt es außerdem
angesichts der eklatanten missachtung
internationaler verpflichtungen durch
das regime sei die eu bereit weitere
maßnahmen in erwägung zu ziehen
die eu hat wie die usa bereits
sanktionen gegen den machtapparat in
minsk verhängt
zur krone lage in deutschland mit den
aktuellen zahlen vom robert koch
institut
es wurden 3127 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden registriert 1030 mehr als vor
einer woche
vier weitere todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit kuwait 19 wurden innerhalb eines
tages gemeldet die sieben tage incident
steigt weiter auf 22,6 mit gut einem
jahr verzögerung ist der österreichische
schriftsteller und essayist christoph
ransmayr wird den ludwig-börne-preis
2020 ausgezeichnet worden
verliehen wurde er von bundespräsident
steinmeier auf schloss bellevue ganz
meiner nehme seine leser gefangen und
entlasse sie dann als neu und anders
sehen der hieß es in der laudatio
so ganz neues bekanntesten werken
gehören die romane die letzte welt und
der fliegende berg eines der themen die
nächste woche die nachrichten bestimmen
werden haben wir heute der sendung ja
schon behandelt den neuen bericht des
weltklimarats der morgen vorgestellt
wird
weitere termine die nächste woche
wichtig werden fasst jetzt anna kaiser
zusammen in unserem sonntäglichen
ausblick
[Musik]
diese bilder aus belarus werden am
montag ein jahr alt sein die friedlichen
massenproteste gegen eine als gefälscht
geltende wahl wurden von machthaber
alexander lukaschenko gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen
zehntausende welle russinnen sind
geflüchtet opposition und medien werden
nach wie vor bedroht und unterdrückt
welche massnahmen braucht es im kampf
gegen die pandemie
darüber will die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am dienstag
angesichts steigender instanzen beraten
das zweite große thema von bund und
ländern die hilfen für die
hochwassergebiete
echte fans statt pappe in der fußball
bundesliga am freitag wird vor bis zu
23.000 zuschauern gespielt auf dem platz
stehen die spieler von borussia
mönchengladbach und des fc bayern
münchen
am 13 august 1961 wurde ein volk
eingesperrt die mauer teilte die stadt
für mehr als 28 jahre
bei zahllosen fluchtversuchen starben
allein in berlin mindestens 136 menschen
bundespräsident steinmeier wird am
samstag der opfer gedenken
bleibt noch der blick aufs wetter zum
start in die neue woche
der montag beginnt freundlich später
bilden sich vor allem im nordwesten und
an den alpen schauer und gewitter an der
nordsee wieder ein stark böiger wind die
temperatur erreicht 19 bis 25 grad
am dienstag gibt es nochmal einige
schauer und gewitter dann aber setzt
sich häufiger die sonne durch und es
wird auch wärmer am donnerstag liegt die
höchsttemperatur zwischen 22 und 30 grad
es war von uns beiden im heute-journal
und gegen 0.30 gibt's die nächste heute
express ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen sonntagabend